we are rapidly seeing a civil war  develop between pro-trump congresswoman  Marjorie Taylor green and pro-trump  congresswoman Lauren bober now we've  seen within the Republican Party the  anti and pro-trump wings fight  this is a fight within the Maga trumpist  right and the fight is over who should  be Speaker of the House some believe it  should be Kevin McCarthy some do not  quite frankly I don't care my interest  is the party destroying itself to the  extent that it will  and Marjorie Taylor green fighting with  Lauren bobert is a really great way to  try to make that happen  um I don't ultimately know who will  prevail a speaker for Republicans once  they take over in January but if we want  to see chaos one of the best things is  the fragmentation of the Republican  party we have the pro anti-trump  fragmentation already seeing the  pro-trump wing further fracture would be  a fantastic thing we should encourage it